This is economics to 50 to a financial markets.
Uh,
and,
uh,
Bob Schiller and let me begin by introducing the teaching fellows for this
course.
And so I have them up here.
Uh,
we have,
uh,
five teaching fellows at this time.
Uh,
and uh,
they're from all over.
I'd like to put their pictures up so you'll know who they are.
Uh,
uh,
the teaching fellows are very international,
and that the reflects my intention to make this a course,
which is also very international because finance is something about the whole
world today,
not just the United States.
So we cover the world very well with our tas.
A Westmont Ali is from Pakistan,
Lahore,
uh,
and,
graduated from the,
uh,
Lems Lah Hor University of management science.
He's a phd candidate now in economics,
uh,
and uh,
is doing his doctoral dissertation on a stock analysts recommendations and the
relation to returns in the stock market.
He's also interested in behavioral finance,
which is the application of psychology to finance.
Um,
the second teaching assistant,
I see him right there.
You could raise your hand is Santosh honor [inaudible] who is a representative
of the United States.
Uh,
although he seems to have connections to India as well.
he's uh,
uh,
he actually has a publication already in the American Economic Review on the
return to capital with Ghana.
And he did this jointly with the chairman of the Economics Department here.
Chris,
you'd be,
and he has spent time in India looking at the,
the village economies and you were going to be giving away cows.
Did you do that?
Okay.
That's the last time you'll hear about cows in this course.
But the idea was to give cows away to village farmers into observe the outcome.
It's a big change in some of these very poor villages to get a cow,
uh,
a Christian,
oh,
Wilco Boudou is from Ghana Accra,
but he again went to college in the United States at Morehouse college and he is
also a phd candidate,
a and economics at Yale.
Uh,
and he's been doing research on financial markets in developing countries.
yeah,
machine dawn,
uh,
is,
from China.
Uh,
she got her undergraduate degree from Nanjing University.
No,
you are from Nanjing.
Did I get to detail wrong?
Where did you go to college?
Okay,
well,
so,
um,
I'm sorry about that.
Uh,
she,
uh,
is also a phd candidate and economics is doing research on the behavior of
options prices in a phenomenon called the options smile.
And she's smiling at me right now.
Uh,
and uh,
she is,
uh,
also interested in behavioral finance,
which is a great to me because that's one of my,
uh,
she has shown here,
standing for carelessly on a cliff.
Uh,
it makes me nervous to look at it overlooking Machu Picchu in Peru.
and she also loves astronomy,
which is incidentally an interest of mine too,
but you won't hear about it again in this course.
And behind the Chalan Ju,
uh,
is,
our fifth,
a teaching assistant and she's also from China who bay province,
uh,
when you graduated from Wu Han University and a phd candidate in economics at
Yale and is doing a research on bank mergers.
Okay.
So,
um,
I'll,
let me see.
I've been teaching this course now for over 20 years,
and I'm very proud of all of my alumni.
Many of them are in the field of finance.
Uh,
in fact,
I liked sometimes when I give talks,
I give a lot of public talks.
When I give a talk on Wall Street or even somewhere else in the world,
I sometimes ask my audience,
did you take my course?
Uh,
and it's not infrequent that I'll get one or even two people raising their hand
that they took,
uh,
economics to 52 from me.
So,
uh,
but I'm also proud of my alumni in this course who are not in the world of
finance.
I think this course is,
it goes beyond,
it's not just for people who are planning careers in finance,
um,
because,
uh,
finance is a very important technology and it's very important to know finance
to understand what happens in the real world.
Just about any human endeavor involves finance that you might say,
I could be a poet.
And what does that have to do with finance?
Well,
it probably ends up having something to do with finance because as a poet,
you probably want to publish your poetry,
right?
And you're going to be talking to publishers and before you know it,
they're going to be talking about their financial situation and how you fit into
it.
So I believe it's fundamental and very important.
And so I think,
uh,
you,
we'll find this course as not a vocational course,
not primarily a vacational vocational course,
but an intellectual course about how things work really work.
I mean,
I see finances the underpinning of so much that happens.
It's a powerful force that goes behind the scene.
Uh,
and I hope we can draw that out in this course.
There is another course in that we have two basic courses in finance for
undergraduates at.
Yeah.
Uh,
the other one is economics to 51,
uh,
financial theory.
This is financial markets.
That one is financial theory.
Last year,
uh,
it was taught by Raphael Romo.
Uh,
that was because John John Accomplice,
who usually teaches the course,
uh,
was on leave.
And so,
um,
and so we had to find someone else,
but I assume that next for John John Accomplice will be again teaching two 51.
So what happened?
Why do we have these two courses?
Well,
it was something like eight years ago that we reached the present,
uh,
um,
situation with two finance courses and John John Akopoulos and I had a meeting
and we tried to divide up the subject matter of finance into two courses.
And so we thought financial theory and financial markets would be the two.
Uh,
but the problem was that both John and I are interested both in theory and a
there and applications.
Uh,
John John Accomplice is actually chief economist for a large investment company
called Ellington Capitol in Greenwich,
Connecticut,
which you'll see a lot in the news.
It's been very successful.
Uh,
and so he's very much interested in the real world.
and so am I interested in financial theory?
And so we find it,
we decided after talking about it that we really can't divide up the subject
matter of finance into separate courses on theory and practice.
Uh,
the either one,
if you tried to do one alone,
it would not work.
Uh,
so what we decided to do was to divide it up in perfectly,
and there may be some repetition between our two courses.
Both of them are self contained courses.
So you could take either two 51 or two 52 or you could take both.
Uh,
and I think maybe the best option is to take both if you're really interested in
the subject matter.
Um,
but,
uh,
it is true though that his core is more tuned into theoretical detail than mine.
Uh,
and,
uh,
John is a mathematical economist.
Uh,
and,
and I,
we both loved mathematics,
but maybe John is going to do more of it than,
than I am.
This course actually will not use a heavy amount of,
of mathematics.
Um,
uh,
I'll,
I'll try to keep it so that people who are not comfortable with a lot of math
would take this course.
Uh,
and so,
um,
but,
uh,
so I wanted to emphasize that this is,
um,
I,
I've said that it's,
I think this course is vocational preparation in a sense.
I pride myself on the fact that people who've taken this course find it useful
in their subsequent lives.
Uh,
but on the other hand,
I think that it's a really interesting,
at least I find it really interesting.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
I hope that you will too.
Now,
I don't know,
I may be different than other people.
I think organic chemistry is really interesting.
How many of you have that feeling?
Uh,
you got a show of hands who's interested in organic chemistry or not getting a
lot of hands raised?
Uh,
unfortunately,
uh,
I've never taken a course in it,
but I've started reading it lately out of just my broad intellectual interest.
Uh,
that is a course that has a bad reputation,
doesn't it?
Because people say,
I've got to take that if I want to be a medical premed.
Um,
but you know,
to me,
uh,
there's a lot of detail in organic chemistry to me when you read the detail,
you're getting into,
uh,
something deep and important about the way everything works.
And so I start to find it interesting.
So I don't know how people feel about taking bigger.
I'm turning you off by saying this.
There's going to be a lot of detail in this course,
but I never made a big mistake by likening it to an organic chemistry course.
I don't mean to turn you off.
Uh,
the idea in this course is that,
uh,
it being a financial markets course is you have to know how the world works.
We're going to be thinking about that in connection with financial theory,
but we have to get into the details.
Uh,
and so we are going to be,
um,
we are going to be learning about a fact.
Uh,
and so,
um,
so let me,
uh,
let me start by talking about the textbook.
So the,
uh,
the principal textbook,
is,
uh,
frank for Bozi,
the other authors are Modigliani Jones and fairy,
um,
and,
uh,
foundations of financial markets and institutions.
Uh,
this textbook,
uh,
is,
very detailed and,
uh,
it,
it may be some,
I've had some reaction to students that's more than I wanted to know.
Uh,
but,
uh,
I actually had a great experience reading it.
I actually,
it was an earlier edition when I first assigned this book in the year 2000.
I took it with me on vacation.
I was going to The Bahamas with my family and with Jeremy Siegel's family,
but we'll come back to Jeremy Siegel in a minute.
Uh,
and I sat down by the pool with this book.
other people were reading novels and I don't know why,
but I was reading,
um,
for Bozi et al and I had such a great time with it.
So I'm telling you that was my experience.
Maybe it was because it was filling in gaps in my knowledge and things I've
always wanted to know and was always curious about.
Um,
that's part of what you have to develop when you get interested in the field to
some sense of curiosity about all the details.
So I read the whole book,
uh,
it's 650 pages,
on our community.
I kind of speed read it cause I knew a lot of it.
They might take you a little longer to get through it.
Um,
and so I wanted you to have the same experience.
so I'm going to sign this book now.
It's now a in another edition and for Bozi is working on a fourth or next
edition.
I forget what number.
Uh,
and uh,
so I'm going to sign you,
I'd gotten some complaints from students that this book is tough going,
uh,
because there's so much information in it.
Uh,
I used to tell people that I'm assigning the whole book and you have to know
everything in the book.
Okay?
Uh,
and that's a little ambitious.
I finally backed down because I met a man on Wall Street,
a very prominent Wall Street person.
And he said,
you know,
my son started to take your course.
Uh,
and I said,
what do you mean started to take your course?
And he said,
well,
he dropped out when he saw this book and my requirements and I didn't like that.
I don't want students to drop out.
So what I decided is to say that you need to know the whole book in the sense
that you need to know all the key terms and key points.
Now,
if you look at the structure of this book,
it has sections that say key points and key terms.
Okay.
That anything that's mentioned there is fair game for me in an exam.
And so,
uh,
that's the way I've done it.
So there are key points and key terms also,
anything in my lecture,
of course it's fair game for the exam.
Uh,
and uh,
oh,
let me also add,
I've got a reading list that has clickable things on it and also things that are
unresolved in the library.
Anything that's clickable is required reading.
Okay.
I don't expect you to go to the library,
however,
uh,
cause I don't,
I think that we're moving into an age where,
uh,
you,
tend to want to be online.
Right?
So,
uh,
the library books are all optional,
um,
background.
Uh,
so for Bozi,
a faculty member here at Yale,
uh,
has offered to give me at least we have at least one chapter from the new
addition that's hasn't come out yet and I'm going to put that on reserve,
uh,
in the library.
Uh,
but again,
I think that the addition that you have is,
uh,
is reasonably uptodate.
And so that's all that I'm expecting you to read.
The other author of Franco Modigliani,
uh,
in the book,
the second author,
uh,
was a,
was my teacher at Mit.
Uh,
he died in 2003.
he also is a Nobel Prize winner,
uh,
and I think is a remarkable intellect.
Uh,
so this book for Bozi et Al,
uh,
for those for Bozi Modigliani Jones and ferry is a very solid book about
financial markets.
Uh,
the second book that I'm assigning is,
uh,
Jeremy Siegel,
stocks for the long run.
Uh,
so,
uh,
this is an old friend of mine.
I met him in graduate school.
A funny story.
I met him because at MIT they,
they,
uh,
signed us all up for chest x rays alphabetically.
That's the way MIT does things in an orderly way.
And Schiller and seagull are next to each other in the alphabet.
So I was standing in line with him for an x ray and I got to talking with him
and I've known him ever since.
It's a funny coincidence is that since our books,
our names are close in the alphabet,
you often find our books right together in bookstores because Shiller and
Siegel,
if their shelving alphabetically would end up together.
Uh,
he wrote a book called stocks for the long run starting in 1993 and it's just,
just came out with the fourth edition.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
that book was a bestseller.
I think it's sold over a half a million copies.
Uh,
I'm not sure where it is up now,
but,
uh,
it has done very well.
It's been a perennial classic,
uh,
and it's really,
it's,
it emphasizes the long run performance of the stock market,
but it's really a
general treatise on financial markets.
Uh,
and I,
I get a very good reaction from this students for this book.
This one is very readable.
It's not so intense as full Bozi et al.
Uh,
Jeremy Siegel has the unique distinction.
Businessweek,
uh,
asked,
did a poll,
asking a Mbas who is their favorite professor?
Uh,
this is about 10 years ago.
And they rank business school professors according to their popularity.
He came out number one in the United States as a business school professor.
And uh,
so I think you'll like this book.
The next book is my own,
uh,
called irrational exuberance.
And this is the last book,
uh,
that's a phrase that was coined by Alan Greenspan,
in 1996.
Uh,
and it refers to the stock market boom of the,
uh,
two thousands,
of the 1990s and the boom and the bust.
Well,
I think it's related to the bus that came out later after 2000.
I wrote this book in 2000,
uh,
right at the peak,
fortunately right at the peak of the stock market.
Uh,
and but what I'm assigning to you is the second edition,
which came out in 2005,
uh,
pretty much at the peak of the housing market.
Uh,
and so we're going to talk about,
uh,
both the housing market and the stock market in these different books.
These books are all on sale at labyrinth books,
which is an independent bookstore here in new haven.
I put it there because,
uh,
well I think,
the major chain bookstores fulfill an important function,
but I like also to support independent bookstores.
And I don't know if you know the story labyrinth books,
uh,
is independent.
It's not a chain a and independent bookstores are trying to,
struggling to survive.
This is finance in the book business.
Uh,
there's something,
uh,
difficult,
about maintaining an independent operation.
So labyrinth was at Columbia University and Yale,
for some reason they shut down their Columbia bookstore,
but they've opened up now in Princeton.
Uh,
there was this famous bookstore on Princeton on Nassau street called makeovers,
which is a wonderful bookstore and I've been in there the number of times,
but they just went out of business.
Uh,
so labyrinth has moved in to take their place.
anyway,
that's where the books,
all the books are and uh,
um,
and they are,
I check they're available now then.
Um,
so,
uh,
we're going to have these lectures are Monday,
I Wednesday we're going to have ta sections on the second part of the week.
We're going to ask you to look at your schedule sometime before our next lecture
and think about when you can come to a teaching assistant section.
Uh,
but they will be Wednesday,
Thursday,
and Friday.
And we have six problem sets,
the six problems sets or do a on generally on Mondays.
And so we'll go over the problem sets in the teaching,
uh,
sections,
a couple days,
several days after you turn them in.
Um,
this is one of the biggest classes at Yale,
but I think,
uh,
we've got,
I think we've got it.
So it will be a good and satisfying experience with you.
We have a very qualified,
I'm very impressed with our teaching assistants.
The important thing is for you to,
uh,
stay with them and get to know them.
Uh,
and I urge you to attend the ta sections.
The course is going to be graded.
Uh,
we have,
uh,
two midterms and one final.
The in class midterms,
the grades will be roughly 10% problems sets 20% first midterm,
30%,
second midterm,
40% final.
Uh,
but nonetheless,
we will also use judgment.
And I'm going to appeal to the TA's to help me on judging the degrading.
Uh,
and,
um,
so I,
uh,
also I asked the teaching assistants to give me a little capsule descriptions of
you so that 10 years or 20 years from now,
and I get a call from a reporter asking about this illustrious person who was
once my student,
uh,
I can have something to proud my memory.
Uh,
so,
uh,
that's what I hope you'll stay with you each find a teaching assistant and we'll
stay with that person.
Um,
so,
uh,
I wanted to say something,
about,
uh,
a particular interest of mine,
because it is part of this course as well,
not the entire course.
Behavioral finance refers to a revolution in finance that's occurred,
uh,
over the last 10 or 20 years.
Uh,
and that is,
uh,
incorporate behavioral finance is the theory of finance mixed in with the
theories of other social sciences.
Uh,
notably a psychology,
sociology,
political science,
anthropology.
Uh,
it's,
um,
and it's,
I think it's the most important revolution in finance of the last couple of
decades.
Uh,
maybe I'm biased because I've been very much involved in it.
I've been organizing workshops in behavioral finance at the National Bureau for
Economic Research now since 1991 with a Dick Thaler at the University of
Chicago.
Uh,
we think that we're on the vanguard of a major revolution.
the unity of the social sciences is,
I think very important.
It's,
it's a mistake to try to consider finance in isolation.
There is a whole array of other information related to finance.
So this will be a theme of my course.
And of course,
it's also a theme of this book here.
Irrational exuberance.
Uh,
that's what it,
what exuberance refers to is a psychological term.
So,
uh,
that's um,
an important element of,
of this course.
Um,
another thing that I will be talking about is less important to discourse,
but
you've heard of this,
the subprime crisis.
Uh,
this is the big financial event,
which is hitting the United States and the entire world right now.
Uh,
and,
uh,
I'm actually writing another book about,
this is not done in time for you to read,
but,
uh,
I think I will have it done at some time during this semester.
Uh,
what does this mean?
Sub Prime refers to the,
uh,
mortgages that were made much mostly over the last 10 years or so to subprime
borrowers.
A subprime borrower is somebody who has a poor credit history or some other
indication that would suggest that they might not be able to repay the mortgage.
They might default,
uh,
the industry,
subprime lending has grown dramatically over the last 10 years and as you
probably know,
uh,
it's in big trouble now what's happening is the housing market is dropping home,
prices are falling and people are defaulting in record numbers and there are
foreclosures.
What happens if you don't pay your mortgage?
You buy a house and you don't pay the mortgage.
The contract says you lose the house.
You're out,
you got to pay.
Or it goes back to the,
uh,
mortgage originator.
Uh,
and,
uh,
this crisis is very interesting to me because it's had so many ramifications
throughout the financial world.
It's exposing defects in many of our biggest financial institution.
And we,
every day we see more news about failures,
a huge losses,
resignations or firings of top of finance people.
So it's a very interesting time,
uh,
in finance,
these things happen from time to time,
but they happen with enough regularity that there's something that we really
want to understand as a systematic,
uh,
as a systematic,
phenomenon.
So that's another thing that I will be talking about.
Um,
the make another point.
But technology,
alright,
finance I believe is a technology and that means it is a way of doing things.
It has a lot of detail.
A financial instrument is like,
uh,
an engineering device here.
I'm tying and none of the engineering's anyone here from engineering?
A couple of you.
Okay.
Well this could be,
in fact,
some engineering schools offer courses in finance and you know that engineers
find it congenial because they have a way of thinking constructively about the
world.
Uh,
that,
uh,
is kind of parallel to finance.
It's a,
we have theories,
mathematical theories that lead us to devise a device.
Uh,
financial structures and financial structures are complicated devices just like
engines are,
or nuclear reactors are.
Uh,
they have a lot of components.
They have to work right.
When people first devise some new financial instrument,
it typically has trouble,
uh,
and just like when they revise the first engines or the first nuclear reactors,
it didn't work so well at first.
And then from experience of many people working on it over many years,
a body of knowledge emerges.
And that's what we call technology.
So technology is a powerful force in our society and I respect power of this
kind.
Uh,
and that's where I like to follow it up.
but technology is also dangerous.
Uh,
so nuclear power,
for example,
it may be our salvation when we run out of oil,
uh,
or virtually run out of oil.
It seems to be coming up over the next few or several decades.
We're going to have to do that.
We're going to need nuclear power,
but it's also dangerous as you know.
Uh,
the same thing is true about finance.
And I think that,
you know,
in a sense the,
the subprime crisis that we have is an example of the dangers of new technology.
We have been seeing financial technology advanced,
uh,
in recent years and this advancement of technology,
has brought us some problems.
Uh,
some people want to go back,
some people think,
ah,
there's a lot of anger about the subprime crisis and there's some anger
expressed against the financial community.
Uh,
I think that we should be very careful not to let that deflect us from the
recognition that this is important technology and that it's not the technology
that's at fault.
We have to get it right and then it will be powerful.
Um,
I've had,
uh,
some experience giving talks in less developed countries.
I'm not a development economist now development you cannot with us.
Santosha is field.
Uh,
uh,
development.
Economics is a very important field in economics,
which is helping,
uh,
less developed countries emerge.
And I'm very proud to say that Yale has a strong department,
uh,
at the growth center of on development economics.
Uh,
I'm not a development economist.
Nonetheless,
when I've spoken in less developed countries,
I find that they're really interested in finance.
Uh,
I think that's because there's a growing recognition that that's what you need
to know.
And that the countries that are emerging successfully are those that have well
developed or financial institutions that are adopting the technology.
They have to adapt it to their own situation,
but in many ways,
they're copying technology.
And there's nothing bad about copying technology.
That's what everybody does,
right?
When somebody invented the automobile before he know everyone's driving
automobiles and they all look pretty much the same.
Uh,
and we,
when someone invented the airplane,
before,
you know,
it,
every country has airplane.
That's because there's a best practice.
There's a best technology and it's not renege to any one country.
So,
um,
so that's why I view this course as,
as a fundamentally about technology.
Uh,
and uh,
uh,
so it's,
um,
uh,
what did it say?
Something about morality,
uh,
and about Ms. Mixed feelings that people have about finance.
Uh,
the,
uh,
I note that undergraduate,
I don't know if how you feel about fine.
Some people have a reaction.
If you say you're taking a course in finance,
they think that maybe you were selling out,
maybe you value money too much,
uh,
that,
you should really be in some other field that,
uh,
this is a long standing,
conflict in our thinking.
There is,
uh,
some contempt for finance,
I believe,
uh,
because it,
because it makes so much money for many people.
Many of our students go into finance.
Yale is very strong and providing people to the financial community.
And I have to say they do very well.
Um,
and so I,
my first advice is if you want to make money,
which I don't particularly advise,
but if you do,
it's not a bad idea to go into finance.
Just as you know,
you can make a lot of money with organic chemistry.
Two,
I think that what you have to do as a young person is develop your,
your human capital and that means how knowing how to do things.
Uh,
but,
uh,
there is,
there is a hostility toward,
uh,
finance that I think is,
that is very fundamental to a lot of our thinking.
We wanted to say something about that.
Um,
uh,
part of it is that some people in finance gets so rich.
Unfortunately,
if you look at the list of the richest people,
uh,
you know,
they're all connected to finance,
right?
I mean,
they understand it.
Maybe they're not,
maybe they're in publishing or some other field,
but they understand finance and a lot of them are directly in finance.
So what do we make of that?
Well,
part of it is that we get,
uh,
we get very,
um,
uh,
you know,
we,
we get a sort of jealousy of these people because,
you know,
why should someone have billions of dollars?
Did they really deserve that?
Uh,
and you know,
some people,
uh,
get self important,
um,
in,
uh,
who make a lot of money.
And,
uh,
they ended up not making a lot of friends in the,
in the process.
Uh,
I was,
uh,
the Yale University press is publishing a new book by Steve Fraser About,
about Wall Street.
Uh,
and he gives examples in this book about hostility toward,
it goes way back.
Uh,
so in Frazer,
his book,
He gives an example of a,
I've never heard of this person before,
but William Door,
uh,
William Door,
who was a finance here,
uh,
and colonial America,
in the 17 hundreds,
um,
made a lot of money and help finance the revolutionary war and the United
States.
Uh,
but he ended up being chased down the street by an angry mob.
People hated him.
Uh,
and why was that?
Well,
it's partly because he got so rich,
uh,
and he,
diary wanting to show off.
He had what they call liveried servants.
Uh,
not just servants,
but servants who were wearing livery,
which means like a military uniform.
And it looked a,
it looked like aristocracy coming back in the form of,
of,
uh,
rich,
finance,
financial successes.
And,
uh,
we don't like that there's a feeling of hostility toward that.
Uh,
and,
um,
there's been a long discussion about what people owe each other and how okay it
is to try to make money.
Uh,
I don't know if you remember,
uh,
I have to start erasing here.
Um,
one of the most well known Yale professors of the 19th century
was
William Graham
Sumner,
uh,
who,
wrote a famous piece called what social classes know each other.
He,
uh,
some there graduated Yale 1863.
He was a member of skull and bones.
You've heard of that?
I thought,
I didn't know that group spent his entire career at Yale.
Uh,
and he wrote,
it was,
he was head of our social sciences department.
That's before we had a separate departments of economics and psychology,
et Cetera.
Uh,
and he was a very prominent,
uh,
exponent of the idea that people should go out for their own interest.
They do.
One social class does not owe anything to another,
and we should not feel guilty about,
about pursuing financial interests.
Uh,
but,
uh,
and that led to a whole attitude among,
among,
uh,
at least a good segment of our society that it's okay to go out and make money
because making money means doing productive things for the economy.
Uh,
and,
uh,
ultimately,
um,
it's a benefit to society.
Um,
but we have some discomfort with that.
Uh,
so,
uh,
another book which I haven't put on reserve yet,
but I'm going to put it on reserve,
uh,
is by Peter Unger,
who is a philosopher.
It's a remarkable book called living high and letting die.
Uh,
and it refers to a more broad philosophical issue that we have.
And that is that,
uh,
most of us are really making money for ourselves.
That's what we do with our lives.
Uh,
and,
uh,
um,
is that moral that it's not just rich people who do that.
The rest of us do it also.
Uh,
and,
uh,
in,
Peter Unger,
his book,
uh,
he,
um,
uh,
on the first page he has an address,
and it's an address for UNICEF,
which is the United Nations Children's Fund.
And he starts out his book with that address where you could send money.
Right now,
I thought it was very impressive that he put that on page one of the book
because it puts the reader in a moral dilemma.
Uh,
he points out that it's estimated that for every $3 you sound to,
you can save a life.
Uh,
that's because there are people in this world who are not getting medical care.
There are people who are dying of diseases for which there are known cures
because they don't have the medical,
the,
the best medicines,
which are often not even expensive,
but they're living in such poverty.
So he says,
why don't you stop right now and send $100 to UNICEF?
Okay.
Um,
and it was very impactful to start a book that way because I doubt that hardly
any readers actually write out a check on the spot,
the UNICEF.
Uh,
and if you don't,
then you are in some sense responsible for the loss of 30 lives.
Uh,
and so it's quite striking and that helps you to reflect on what makes us,
what makes us,
uh,
behave the way we do.
By the way,
when you go back to your computer,
okay,
Google,
UNICEF,
and you can give $100 to UNICEF,
uh,
with it,
you can do it within the hour.
Okay.
Uh,
maybe I could ask for a show of hands how many people did have,
uh,
I expect that not many of you will,
and I don't think that proves that you're bad people.
This is a very interesting philosophical question.
Uh,
but,
uh,
what it means is that,
whether there is a moral dilemma underlying all of our economic lives,
uh,
and I think this moral dilemma is the same as the moral dilemma in finance.
So I'm in the financial,
it's just that people in finance are sometimes very successful and they could
give a lot more than a hundred dollars to UNICEF.
Um,
so one thing that I wanted to emphasize in this course,
I'll try to emphasize is that a part of finance,
uh,
is actually fun philanthropy.
Uh,
and so the most important,
the most successful people in finance,
I believe,
end up giving the money away.
Okay.
And that means,
uh,
you can't consume $1 billion.
There's no way that you can do that.
What they end up,
uh,
you,
you can only drive one car at a time.
Right?
And if you have five cars,
well,
I mean,
that's kind of a,
all right.
You could have five cars and you can drive a different one every day,
but it's starting to seem a little ridiculous,
right?
Uh,
in any way.
We're not using them and they're going to end up used by somebody else.
Uh,
so,
uh,
I think the outcome should be philanthropy.
And so those of you who are successful,
uh,
really ought to give it away.
Uh,
so I'm bringing in outside speakers as part of this course and uh,
I'm going to,
uh,
among them bring in people who I think have been a philanthropists,
that,
that's the,
that's the mode of thinking that,
um,
that is most attractive when you think about financial markets.
Uh,
so let me tell you about,
I have slots now for four outside speakers have lined up two of them.
Uh,
and let me tell you about the two that I've already lined up.
the first one is our own David Swensen.
Uh,
David Swensen,
uh,
came to a Yale University in 1985,
from Wall Street,
although he's a Yale.
He was a Yale graduate.
Uh,
at that time,
the Yale Endowment was,
uh,
about,
actually it's slightly under $1 billion.
What does the endowment of year,
the endowment is defined as the financial assets that Yale University owns.
Okay.
Uh,
Yale also has an art collection,
which is worth many billions.
We don't count that as part of the endowment because they will never sell it.
And so it doesn't provide income for us.
And Yale also has a physical plant like this beautiful building that we're in
that's not part of the endowment either.
The financial assets that Yale has a at that time were about a billion dollars.
Um,
so,
um,
since then,
uh,
David Swenson has invested or has managed the investment of this endowment,
and it has done phenomenally well.
So it's now over $22 billion that Yale has in its endowment.
And so the return that he got,
uh,
from 1996 to 2006,
was,
um,
17% a year on,
on investments last year.
The return on the Yale portfolio was 28% in one year.
Now,
I don't know how impressed you or the year before that it was 22% in one year.
Uh,
now some of this might be luck.
but I don't think it's all luck because he's done this consistently for so many
years.
If you look up around this campus now,
you'll see a lot of construction,
a lot of things are being spruced up and improved.
Well that's,
you know,
I think David Swenson has had a big hand in doing that because,
uh,
it's having the money that makes it possible.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
you know,
the endowment at Yale is something like $2 million per student now,
uh,
that's just sitting there as money that could be spent.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
how did he do this?
That's one of the amazing things.
It seems to have something to do.
I think with academic,
um,
understanding that being part of a university community,
uh,
is a good thing for investing.
Uh,
and,
uh,
you,
you can see some evidence in that in that Harvard University,
Princeton University and other universities have done extremely well on their
endowments.
However,
not quite as well as Yale.
Yale I think is the number one performer.
So it's,
uh,
it's very interesting that we're able,
it's very significant that we're able to get David Swensen.
Uh,
he doesn't do a lot of public speaking,
but he is willing for,
for,
uh,
young people like you to do this.
Um,
so,
uh,
that's one of our outside speak.
He also has two books about investing that we'll talk about.
Um,
the second a person I have set up now to come,
although the date,
uh,
on the syllabus online is going to be changed is Andrew Red Leaf,
who is a Yale,
also a Yale graduate,
uh,
and who set up a hedge fund called white box advisers,
and has done phenomenally well in investing.
And uh,
uh,
so I think I have on the syllabus,
I have a New York Times article about him.
He's a very original and creative thinker,
uh,
who looks at things from a unique perspective of,
and I find it very interesting talking with him because,
uh,
to do well and invest in,
you have to have your own independent view of things and really be thinking
about how things work.
Uh,
and he is someone who does that.
Incidentally,
the New York Times had another article about a red leaf,
uh,
saying that he was really one of the first person,
to clearly delineate the subprime crisis that we're now in a,
he saw it coming,
and I have to say,
profited from it.
If,
you know,
the subprime crisis is coming,
there's always a way to profit from that.
Uh,
and that's what he did.
But he also has a philanthropic side,
so it all comes up,
uh,
very,
very well.
So,
uh,
I think in the remaining time I will just go through and outline of the,
um,
an outline of the course,
and,
uh,
that means,
go through the topics of the various lectures.
Uh,
and then I'll let you go for today.
So,
um,
the way this course is divided up is different than the financial theory course.
If you look at John John Accomplice Course on financial theory,
uh,
he's mathematical concepts are central to his outline of the course,
but this being a financial markets,
of course I'm dividing it up more in terms of markets and institutions,
but still I want to start with some theory.
Uh,
and I thought that,
uh,
well I will,
I plan to start by talking about,
uh,
the basic,
the most basic concepts of risk management,
which underlie finance.
Uh,
and so that will be,
uh,
Wednesday's lecture.
They call it the universal principle of risk management pooling and the hedging
of risk.
Uh,
I think it's the most important theoretical concept that underlies finance and
insurance,
uh,
which we'll also talk about a little bit in this course.
And the idea is that if you spread risks,
uh,
they,
they don't disappear.
They're still there,
but they're spread out over many people.
And the impact on any one person is reduced.
So the basic principle of insurance is,
uh,
if,
each person's for each family have suffering is the risk,
for example,
that,
uh,
a parent,
a father or mother might die,
which is a terrible blow to the family,
but it's not a blow to society as a whole because people die and it has a
certain statistical regularity.
So it makes sense that we pay families who have lost a father or mother so that
they can keep going.
It benefits everyone to have a situation in place for that.
I wanted to talk about that with a little bit of reference to probability
theory.
And so,
uh,
that's what,
I will be covering the next lecture.
We'll be among the more mathematical,
although it's very elementary,
if you had a course in probability and statistics,
you'll find it easy to follow.
Uh,
but it's self contained.
Again.
Uh,
I feel like I have to introduce concepts like variance and covariance and a
correlation in order to talk about finances and that.
So that's what we'll do,
uh,
in lecture two.
Uh,
then the next lecture I wanted to come back to some basic themes,
uh,
that,
the third lecture about,
uh,
technology.
Uh,
and this relates to a,
another book that I wrote or not signing it,
but I wrote a book called New Financial Order,
uh,
in 2003,
about technology and finance.
And a theme of that book was that,
uh,
I've already said this to you,
but it's very important point that financial technology is evolving and
improving just the way engineering technology or biochemical technology is
improving.
It's getting better year by year and,
uh,
the,
course of financing over,
uh,
your lifetime will be dramatic.
So,
uh,
the financial institutions that we have 10 years from now will look very
different from the ones we have now.
Uh,
and,
uh,
w w one thing too,
we have to understand in understanding the progress of financial technology is
its fundamental relation to information technology,
computers,
uh,
the Internet communications devices are fundamental to financial progress and
they make things possible that wouldn't have been possible before.
Often inventions,
uh,
that,
that you seem in the abstract to be good ideas may be impossible because
something that you have to do to make it actually come into practice is too
expensive.
And so it's not economic to produce an invention,
but then,
uh,
developments in other parts in other fields can change the relative prices and
suddenly make an,
an idea that had been hypothetical and unapplied suddenly work well.
So financial inventions,
uh,
also involve experimentation.
Like in any other invention,
nobody knows what will work.
Uh,
abstract theory doesn't guide you.
completely,
uh,
and,
once an invention is seen to work,
it is rapidly copied around the world.
Uh,
and so we can see various breaks in financial history.
When some new idea,
suddenly it was proven workable.
Uh,
traditionally financial interventions were not granted patent rights.
But now,
uh,
in the United States,
in a number of other countries,
it's become possible to patent financial,
uh,
inventions.
Uh,
I know I've done that in my,
uh,
in my life.
Uh,
and so I think it's,
um,
uh,
that gives a different perspective on,
on finance.
Uh,
then,
uh,
I want to talk about,
insurance,
uh,
and,
the institution of insurance is something that really came in with one of the
earliest,
um,
uh,
I,
I consider it a division of finance came really in,
in the 16 hundreds when probability theory was invented.
Uh,
the mathematical theory of probability was unknown until that time.
And you can see that,
uh,
insurance suddenly made an appearance,
at that time.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
I,
this will be historical and as well as theoretical discussion of,
of insurance.
Uh,
then I will move to a portfolio diversification,
uh,
and supporting financial institutions.
Uh,
and this is again,
a more theoretical lecture.
It will be about the capital asset pricing model.
Uh,
it will be about,
uh,
the,
um,
uh,
securities market line about the data,
about the mutual fund theorem.
Uh,
but it will also be about institutions that we have about,
uh,
investment companies and their management.
So it's really parallel to an insurance discussion.
Uh,
insurance pools risks,
uh,
like life risks or fire risks by writing policies to individual policy holders.
But,
uh,
portfolio management pools risks in a different way by assembling a diversified
portfolio or a portfolio that's negatively correlated with a risk that someone
has
a,
then I want to go to the efficient market's theory.
Okay.
So efficient markets is a theory about,
um,
uh,
well it came in about the three decades ago,
maybe it's closer to four decades ago.
It's a theory that financial markets work very well and incorporate information
very well.
Uh,
the efficient markets hypothesis was encouraged actually,
the idea goes back over 100 years,
but it's encouraged by the observation that financial markets seem to respond
with great speed to new information.
Uh,
and when new information appears,
prices will suddenly adjust in the financial markets.
Certain kinds of financial markets called prediction markets,
which may for example,
predict the outcome of an election have been seen to be very accurate
predictors.
Uh,
often better than pollsters,
uh,
can manage.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
there seems to be some deep wisdom of the market.
Uh,
I think that is an important,
efficient markets is an important concept.
On the other hand,
uh,
and this is something that I want to,
emphasize that you don't want to carry that too far.
Uh,
and that,
uh,
one of the lessons of behavioral finance is that markets are not really
efficient in a global sense.
Uh,
human psychology drives markets a great deal.
If markets were perfectly efficient,
David Swensen could not have done what he did.
Uh,
it would be not possible to make a access returns in finance.
I believe it's clear that it is,
and that people who do that are people who understand more than the core
efficient markets theory.
They understand something about human nature,
how the human nature interacts with our institutions.
Uh,
the next lecture is about behavioral finance.
and so I want to talk in that lecture about research in psychology,
uh,
things that come out of the,
another department here,
the psychology department,
which,
uh,
have traditionally been in economics.
And finance,
but are,
are coming back more.
Uh,
I want to talk about Conaman and diversity's prospect theory,
which is a,
uh,
very important.
Um,
and this'll be a little technical psychologist can become mathematical and
technical as well.
It'll be an important part of our understanding of financial markets.
Uh,
no.
I want to talk in the next lecture about regulation.
Uh,
and that means,
uh,
government oversight of financial market and not just government oversight.
There are also the so called self regulatory organizations that are created in
the financial industry to self regulate.
So,
uh,
for example,
Finra,
uh,
which used to be called the National Association of securities dealers is an
organization,
a membership organization of uh,
people in the financial community and it imposes rules on its member.
It's not a government organization,
uh,
but it's a regulator.
Uh,
and uh,
the problem is that,
uh,
not everyone is nice and not one.
Everyone is high minded.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
financial markets,
the success of financial markets is in many ways a success of regulation.
Uh,
governments establish regulators who set down rules for participants in
financial markets.
Uh,
and these rules may be perceived as honorous and costly to people in the
financial community,
but ultimately it's their salvation.
It's what makes everything possible.
Uh,
after that,
I want to talk about,
uh,
about,
debt markets now.
Um,
that is,
uh,
the simplest of financial instruments.
It consists of a promise to pay,
uh,
usually in denominated in currency and there are both long term and short term
debt instruments.
The shortest term a debt instrument in the United States is the federal funds
rate,
which is an overnight rate,
one day maturity.
And uh,
the longest issued by the government is a 30 year government bond.
So that will be repaid three decades in the future.
There have also been hundred year bonds and they've also been perpetuities,
uh,
that,
in the UK for example,
the British console's which have no expiration date there infinite maturity.
Uh,
so,
uh,
the debt market is something worthy of study because it really represents a
market for time itself.
What is it that we're talking about when we talk about the rate of interest?
It has units of time.
It represents the price of time.
And it is something that fluctuates through time as well in interesting
patterns.
Uh,
and there are very important drivers of our economy and our lives.
And,
uh,
the theory of the term structure is the theory of how interest rates differ
through according to maturity or term.
Uh,
there are not only a debt instruments that are related to that are payable in
currency.
There are also indexed that instruments that are indexed to the price level.
And so they give real,
uh,
they give real interest rates.
Uh,
and we've had episodes in our history when real interest rates have made major
moves.
And these movements are very important for what is happening in our lives.
Most recently for a few years,
a few years ago,
we have,
we're living in a regime of negative real interest rates,
uh,
when the Fed was pursuing a very aggressive monetary policy.
I suspect that with the subprime crisis,
the Fed will be pushing real interest rates down dramatically again,
and we may again be in a period of negative real interest rates.
Um,
after that,
I want to talk about the stock market.
Uh,
and I wanted,
uh,
there's a lot to talk about.
Of course stocks are shares in companies and they're traded on stock exchanges.
Uh,
and,
uh,
they're interesting,
to analyze,
uh,
because they,
they,
uh,
there's a sort of ambiguity about stocks that is not widely perceived by a lot
of people.
Uh,
and that is that the share repurchase,
uh,
can change the units of measurement in a security,
and companies have to decide on how leveraged the stock will be.
Uh,
and so that changes the stock price leverage,
meaning how much debt does the company take on?
Uh,
and moreover,
companies have to decide how much dividends to pay on the stock.
That's a decision of the management of the company.
Uh,
and we have to understand how do they make that decision and what does that mean
to people who aren't valuing stocks.
It's a very simple idea,
the idea of dividing a company up into shares and selling them off.
But in practice it involves a lot of complexities.
Uh,
so we'll be talking about the motor,
Yani Miller theorem and related issues in this lecture as well as about
something about the behavior of the stock market and the tendency of it to go
through dramatic movements,
uh,
as for example,
it has done recently.
If you've been following it earlier this year,
the next lecture will be about real estate.
And that brings us in very much into the subprime crisis and it brings,
it connects up with interests that are central to,
to my own,
uh,
thinking.
Uh,
the housing market is a huge market right now.
The total value of single family homes in the United States is about $2
trillion.
Uh,
and,
uh,
the,
the market has becoming,
has been becoming increasingly speculative.
Home prices have gotten unstable.
So nationally,
home prices in the United States rose 85% between 1997 and 2006.
In real terms,
incorrect inflation corrected term,
we've seen almost a doubling in the price of the average home in the United
States.
Why did that happen?
Now they are falling.
And so in real terms,
home prices have fallen almost 10% since the peak in 2006.
This is not just a US phenomenon.
Many countries of the world,
uh,
are experiencing home priced booms and the beginning of what might be a home
price bust.
Uh,
so I want to consider,
uh,
the market for homes,
and,
uh,
also about the market for mortgages,
which are the instruments that finance homes.
To what extent was the housing boom that we saw in recent years?
The result of revolution in financial technology.
Uh,
there's been a lot of changes in our mortgage institutions and that might be
part of the reason for the boom in home prices.
Uh,
and so,
but there's also a question of,
uh,
psychology.
The next lecture we will be about banking.
Uh,
and about,
uh,
the,
the supply of money.
Uh,
the money multiplier.
it's about,
uh,
how banks operate,
what their function is and our society.
Why are they such important institutions that have gone back for hundreds of
years,
uh,
and remain powerful central fee features in our economy.
It's also about bank regulation such things as the Basel accord,
Basel one and Basel two.
I want to also talk about the impact of information and technology and banking.
Uh,
the next lecture is about monetary policy.
the,
uh,
what the central banks do in the United States.
The central bank is called the Federal Reserve.
Uh,
in the United Kingdom,
it's the Bank of England and Japan has the Bank of Japan and the,
uh,
and in Europe it's the European Central Bank.
Uh,
all of these banks are really in control of short term interest rates.
and these interest rates are used to try to,
uh,
to manage and stabilize the economy,
in response to the subprime crisis that we are now in our central bank.
The Federal Reserve has been cutting interest rates aggressively to try to save
a economy that appears to be declining.
I want to try to understand in that lecture,
help us understand how this works and how we're getting,
uh,
how we're getting,
solutions or possible solutions to these problems.
Then I want to talk about investment banking.
Now an investment bank is a different kind of bank.
Uh,
I was talking up to this point about commercial banks and investment bank is not
a bank that accepts deposits.
It doesn't deal with the general public.
It deals instead with financial institutions.
Uh,
and it gets involved in a underwriting of securities for financial institutions.
It's a very important industry and it's also one that many of our students,
uh,
have found jobs in.
So I think it's important for us to try to understand,
uh,
the,
the history of investment banks,
the role that they have in our financial,
uh,
community,
and how they're regulated.
Uh,
then I want to talk about money managers,
professional money managers,
people like David Swensen.
Uh,
these are our people,
our community of people in a different segment of the,
of the financial industry.
These are people who manage portfolios.
Uh,
and,
uh,
we want to think about what kinds of forces operate on them,
what kind of,
uh,
um,
I'm interested in viewing them partly as people who are very expert in a certain
kind of technology who live in a very competitive environment.
Uh,
and try to understand why some of them succeed much more than others,
but it also relates to behavioral finance.
Uh,
and that is that,
uh,
ultimately they are human beings like anyone else.
And some of their differences in success or failure may have to do with their
own,
uh,
interconnections and their own,
psychology and inner personal psychology.
Uh,
then I want to talk about brokerages.
Those are institutions that,
that arrange for or manage the buying and selling of financial assets,
such things as the New York Stock Exchange.
Uh,
now the brokerage industry,
the New York Stock Exchange goes back into the 18th century.
It's very old.
And in fact,
the idea of exotic exchange goes back to the 14th century.
Uh,
went in Flanders,
the first stock exchange called the Boris,
uh,
was,
established.
So it goes back many hundreds of years,
but it's in rapid change now because of information technology.
And,
uh,
it's one of the most rapidly changing,
hard to keep up with areas,
uh,
because someone can set up an electronic exchange over night and suddenly
become,
uh,
a base for a trading of trillions of dollars,
of,
uh,
of securities.
Uh,
so that's it.
It fits in well with the theme of this course about technology because in
understanding what's happening with brokerages,
uh,
our technology,
that the new information technology is central,
then I want to move to futures markets and forward markets.
Uh,
and,
uh,
a forward contract is a contract made between two parties for execution in the
future.
Uh,
they're called generally,
these are called over the counter contracts because they're not arranged through
exchanges.
We also have standardized contracts that are traded on exchanges and they're
called futures contracts.
Uh,
futures contracts were invented in Japan in the 16 hundreds at Osaka.
and they were developed for the rice market in Japan.
They were uniquely Japanese until pretty much the 19th century,
and then they were copied all over the world,
uh,
and are now very important.
Uh,
I'm going to talk about a one futures market that,
um,
I have been an instrumental in developing.
I've been working with the Chicago Mercantile Exchange to create a futures
market for a single family homes.
And that's sort of my connection to the futures industry.
Uh,
but of course there are many futures markets and we'll talk about,
uh,
they're very interesting to me.
Uh,
and I wonder why the business community isn't more aware of it,
but a futures market has a prediction,
uh,
going out years into the future of what every financial variable we'll be doing.
So you can see the future in a sense through the futures prices.
Uh,
it's not always correct to think of it that way,
but,
uh,
we have to get into the theory of futures markets.
In many cases that is not the right way to think about futures prices,
but there are very important futures markets that,
uh,
there are.
Uh,
and so in the next lecture I want to talk about,
uh,
the,
number of the various kinds of futures markets that matter.
We have a stock index futures markets and know that we have an oil futures
market.
Uh,
the oil futures market,
uh,
is very significant because it represents the price of energy on dates into the
future.
We can now see the price of oil going out years into the future.
We've just hit $100 a barrel price of oil.
Uh,
but what does that mean?
Does that mean we're going to live in a world with a hundred dollar oil?
Well,
not if you look at the futures market,
which is in backwardation now and it's predicting major drops in the oil price
of oil.
Uh,
then I want to talk about options markets.
This is getting close to the end of the course.
An option is the right to buy something.
Typically we think of it as a stock option.
A and option is a contract that says you can buy so many shares of,
of a,
of a company.
Uh,
the options have been traded,
uh,
now for several decades starting with the Chicago board options exchange,
but now many options exchanges,
uh,
and we have prices of options that change minute by minute.
And what did these changes in these prices mean?
Uh,
and the options are very useful technology for managing of risks.
and uh,
uh,
I think that we'll see a rapid over the next few decades.
Was he rapid expansion in the scope of options contracts traded on the
exchanges.
And finally,
the last lecture for this semester,
I want to talk about,
uh,
told us together and talk about one of the themes that,
or summarize in terms of a theme of this course,
which is the democratization of finance.
Uh,
finance used to be a very esoteric field that only a few people in London and
terrorists and other worlds centers understood.
It has an Amsterdam and other places where financial technology emerged,
but it's becoming democratized with each year that goes by,
the concepts of finance are being applied more broadly and involving more and
more people with electronic technology.
It's becoming more economical to offer sophisticated financial services to
everyone.
And this is a thing that we're seeing,
I think,
uh,
the subprime crisis that is the current financial crisis,
highlights this very well.
What does sub prime mean?
Well,
I think it stands for the general population.
The subprime mortgage market was bringing people in to the mortgage market,
who in prior decades would not have been involved,
would not have had any mortgage.
The problem,
of course,
with the democratization of finance is that if you raise the participation in
financial markets,
you bring in people who are less and less knowledgeable and less and less
understanding of concepts of finance and less capable and more vulnerable to
exploitation.
So the democratization of finances,
I think the ultimate mission of,
uh,
that I find central to this course,
but it brings with it dangerous and hazards.
And we have to think very carefully about how we do it.